make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are going to be explaining one of the
most interesting concepts maybe not
really interesting that's not very good
word one of the concepts that exists
from marvel comics which is the vision
and scarlet witch's kids
for those of you guys who are curious
because a lot of you guys have asked i
will be explaining the episodes of wanda
vision as they go through because we're
getting them every week i think the
first two come out on the 15th so
here in about about five days or so and
then it's one episode per week after
that but i'll be explaining those
episodes over on pop culture explained
so uh make sure you guys head over there
become a part of the channel and yeah
you'll get your explanations on what's
going on with one division so
the whole idea behind scarlet witch and
the visions kids
is one of these interesting concepts
right so kind of explaining this you
guys all know about the avengers right i
mean you guys don't need me to explain
the avengers or you know the avengers
explain you guys are aware they're a
superhero team that's existed for a long
time
on the avengers team that's where of
course scarlet witch and vision first
met and that's where scarlet witch and
vision fell in love
now this really is really kind of the
building blocks of their relationship
which would really come to a head a
little bit later but there is a story
that not a lot of people
know about that is exceedingly important
to understanding the nature of scarlet
witch's kids and this was fantastic for
number 277 now this is a story where
through some weird and chaotic events
you end up having a fight
between mephisto and franklin richards
when franklin ridgers is still like a
little kid
franklin basically lashes out and uses
the full totality of his reality warping
powers to destroy mephisto in his home
realm to give you guys perspective
mephisto is at his most powerful in his
own realm he's basically or used to be
what was essentially the devil in marvel
comics that's changed now you have
what's called the one below all
uh but mephisto was was what's called a
hell lord so he was like satan to a
degree and marvel he was insanely
powerful in his own realm so much so
that he was actually able to overpower
galactus if that gives you guys any
perspective but in the aftermath of his
fight with franklin mephisto's physical
form was essentially destroyed and his
soul was scattered into five different
pieces now the reason why this matters
is because
around the time that this battle between
franklin and mephisto took place
resulting in
essentially mephisto's death you had the
beginning of vision and the scarlet
witch
volume 2 by steve englehart volume 1 by
bill mantlow was basically just changing
things up with regards to quicksilver
and scarlet witch and whether or not
they were the kids of magneto not really
important for the sake of this
discussion what is important is that in
the second volume would span
12 issues and that's the that's the
series that everybody points to when
they tell you like
read vision and the scarlet witch for
one division that's the one they're
talking about the one written by steve
ingleheart so you can just google steve
ingleheart vision and scarlet witch and
that'll it'll take you exactly to that
to that series but in this series the
scarlet witch becomes pregnant now one
of the big questions people had
is how does scarlet witch become
pregnant right i mean the vision like
he's a robot and he might have the
equipment down there
he might have the capability to like
engage in the act that would get
somebody pregnant but like you know the
engine's running but there's nobody
behind the wheel you understand what i'm
saying like that dog don't bark it just
doesn't work so nobody understood how it
was
that scarlet witch and vision could
basically conceive and have
kits now the reality is that steve
ingelhart did not want uh
did not want vision and the scarlet
witch series to be tied into anything
else right it was supposed to be
standalone by itself cut off from the
entirety of marvel's continuity marvel
comics being marvel comics did the
opposite of that and they basically you
know when you had the events of them
of their solo series ending and then
them going back into uh the west coast
avengers what you ended up seeing
is that with west coast avengers as it
was written by john byrne at the time
that weird things were happening within
the comic book stories you had a woman
by the name of agatha harkness and
agatha harkness served as a babysitter
for like franklin richards whenever the
fantastic four were doing things and she
also served as a babysitter for
uh vision and scarlet witch whenever
they were off doing things you know
performing these various superhero
antics and so what you end up learning
here
is that whenever the scarlet witch and
vision are on a mission and they're
fighting some enemy somewhere and
scarlet witch is in
incredible danger the children will
vanish and it didn't make any sense it
was like why are these kids just
disappearing and that's when agatha
hartness began to kind of look around
and she came to this realization that it
always only ever happens when the
scarlet witch's concentration
is basically put on something else when
she loses her ability to focus
on her kids and that's when i get the
hardness realizes that scarlet witch's
kids are not real they never actually
gave i mean i guess she did give birth
to them right like doctor strange was
there right so he was the reason you
know he was literally helping her
conceive these kids but by all standards
of measurement they are not the
the genetic imprint of vision and
scarlet witch combined into a singular
being right they're not
real children as you and i know them and
so because of that it was kind of like
okay
something's a little amiss here now
during this time with west coast
avengers vol 2 and issue number 45
one of the big things happened with a
vision basically lost his identity right
he was ultimately destroyed and they
recreated him but the brain patterns
that he had were gone so he was just
like this white android he looks
he looks really weird but in issue
number 52 you end up finding out that
that what mephisto had done as a result
of his physical form being destroyed is
he tasked a villain by the name of
master pandemonium with collecting his
five different shards right the five
pieces of mephisto soul in this same
story you actually learned that the kids
of scarlet witch
are two of those pieces of mephisto soul
that she had such a desire to conceive
children
that she subconsciously essentially
snatched up those two souls of mephisto
and then
placed them inside her own body and then
gave birth to kids that way she used
magic to make herself pregnant so in
effect her children were possessed by
the soul of the devil that's essentially
what that means
it's kind of crazy when you think about
it but over the course of these stories
uh
west coast avengers 51 52 and a couple
other stories later you end up basically
having the shards of mephisto
reconstituted and mephisto comes back
a consequence of this is that the
scarlet witch's kids cease to exist
enter agatha harkness using her magic to
effectively
wipe the mind of the scarlet witch so
she has no recollection that she ever
had kids now this was the status quo for
decades right for decades and decades it
was a status quo marvel had this really
really weird
thing where scarlet witch's kids were
basically possessed by the soul of the
devil because they were the devil's soul
and and that was it right it was just
one of these things where was like okay
so poor decision making on behalf of
marvel but
is comic books we'll roll with it this
goes into a story called
avengers disassembled and what ends up
happening is that janet van dyne makes
this off-handed remark about a scarlet
witch's
skull of wish losing her kids and what
it does is it snaps back all these
memories and scarlet witch is just
convinced that she had kids and so what
this does is it leads her to going on a
war path because she ultimately tracks
down
agatha harkness who by this point had
previously died but been resurrected
then she kills her right you know
because of because of the fact that she
felt betrayed that agatha harkness had
wiped her mind and then she just starts
doing all these crazy things right i
mean she she uses her magic to make tony
stark look drunk so basically the
entirety of stark
stark industries their stock value
plummets so he essentially goes broke he
can't bankroll the avengers anymore so
that's why the avengers disassemble
i think she ends up manipulating
she-hulk so she just goes into like this
savage berserker rage and starts
attacking everybody
she summons an entire cree armada over
top of avengers mansion hawkeye dies
scott lang ant-man dies like it's just
it's a crazy set of events but this
basically leads to
to the idea that scarlet witch is just
constantly going on and babbling on
about how like she had kids the avengers
have taken her kids the avengers stole
her kids you know all that kind of stuff
and of course the events of avengers
disassembled go into
house of m but in the aftermath of all
that what you end up getting are the
appearance of a couple different
characters the first one is
wiccan and the second one is speed and
these are characters known as
billy and tommy now they had those names
before when they were originally
introduced in marvel comics as part of
like the vision and scarlet witch
stories they were basically just billy
and tommy the kids of
of wanda but the reality is it wasn't
until you got into the
to the the children's crusade story arc
in marvel comics itself that mama
basically tied all these things together
right up until that point they were just
a couple kids who were there and it was
like okay i mean are they scarlet
witches kids are they not scarlet
witch's kids and marvel never really
bothered to answer but when you finally
get into
uh children's crusade it's effectively
confirmed that they are that they're the
kids of scarlet witch we can cover
avengers crusade if you get i guess
children's crusade if you guys want me
to it's interesting it's nine issues
it's not super long but we can cover it
this week if that's something you guys
are interested in seeing uh but her kids
are really really powerful right they're
they're pretty cool uh speed is
basically modeled after quicksilver
right so he's got super speed wiccan is
the crazy reality warping kid and the
biggest fear they had
was that wiccan would end up being like
the scarlet witch where he would lose
his mind and like you know end up
tearing things
up taking away like 98 of the mutant
population's powers during the events of
house of m or the aftermath of house of
van or possibly doing something worse
because one of the things a lot of
people tend to forget
is the actions of the scarlet witch
during house of m were not confined to
the maine marvel universe that
throughout the entirety of the
multiverse
98 of the mutant population lost their
powers so she affected the whole
multiverse not just the
not just the universe there's actually a
comic that explains it and i want to say
it's a discovery that was found by beast
the whole idea behind this is that how
am i was going gonna do this we don't
really know if i'm a betting man i'll
say that one division is a combination
of age of x and house of m and that
essentially these kids of of scarlet
witch have just kind of been wished into
existence by scarlet witch's powers that
what she's experiencing here
is in effect just a giant mental
breakdown right the entire show is her
just
losing her mind and at the end of it all
we're gonna find out that like she's
just been altering reality on like a
universal scale or something stupid like
that right something that just
dwarfs the power of thanos with the
infinity gauntlet and uh the whole idea
of her and doctor strange traveling into
the multiverse is to basically just
correct all the mistakes she made or to
find out how far reaching the whole
thing is we don't really know we have no
worthy clue at this point we're just
swinging for the fences but yeah that's
the nature
that's kind of the the quick and dirty
explanation on the kids of scarlet witch
and vision right billion and tommy but
yeah if you guys are new here to
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
we will not tolerate incoherence
[Music]
fears